-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
let's get to some news.
Today, Chinese President
Xi Jinping met virtually
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin.
They didn't talk even.
They just spent an hour
exchanging maniacal laughter.
[ Laughing evilly ]
It's not great news for Biden.
I mean, for Marvel fans,
it's like if Spider-Man
found out that Doc Ock
was Zooming
with the Green Goblin.
I mean, something is happening.
[ Laughter ]
But they had a lot to discuss,
like trade, nuclear arms,
and why Carrie
didn't call 9-1-1.
[ Laughter ]
At one point,
Xi called Putin his old friend,
and Putin called Xi
his dear friend.
Then they ended the call like,
"You hack us first,"
"No, you hack us first!"
"Oh, no, you hack us first!"
[ Laughter ]
Some big news in Washington.
The House voted to hold
former Trump chief of staff
Mark Meadows
in criminal contempt of Congress
for refusing to cooperate
with the January 6th panel.
The consequences are severe.
Meadows could be sentenced
to a year in prison,
or, even worse,
another month working for Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
Meadows needs a good lawyer,
so the first thing he did
was pull up
Rudy Giuliani's number
and delete it.
[ Laughter ]
Some more news.
The White House just announced
that, due to COVID concerns,
instead of the traditional
holiday parties,
he's inviting guests
to come see the decorations
on a 30-minute self-guided tour.
[ Light laughter ]
Which is just a fancy way
of Biden saying,
"Come if you want,
but I ain't gonna be there."
[ Laughter ]
"I ain't getting COVID."
[ Light laughter ]
So guests can now go
on a 30-minute self-guided tour
of an old mansion.
There's actually a name
for that --
it's called a haunted house.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
A self-guided tour
of a historic
Washington building.
That's basically how Fox News
described January 6th.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this -- I heard that
pharmacists across the country
are feeling burned out
due to increased demand
for COVID shots
and being short-staffed.
Yeah, I'm sure it's that
and not just hearing
The Chipmunks Christmas on loop
for two months.
It's like, "I'm losing it, Gary.
I'm losing it.
Get him a hula hoop!
Get them a hula hoop!"
[ Laughter ]
You know your pharmacist
is stressed out
when they disinfect your arm
with the Bacardi
from their flask.
"Shot for you, shot for me,
right?"
[ Laughter ]
It's gotten so bad now,
when you order Xanax,
the pharmacist says,
"We just ran out."
[ Laughter ]
Get this.
In Canada, a 5-year-old is safe
after he was caught driving
his parents' car
to go buy a Christmas present
for his sister.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
The cop asked him to recite
the alphabet backwards,
and he was like, "I haven't even
learned it forwards."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's in a lot of trouble,
so, really, his sister got
the greatest gift of all.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the kid showed
each officer a packet
of Dunkaroos and said,
"How about we, uh,
say this never happened?"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, this is something
you don't hear every day.
Authorities in Ohio
are investigating
after someone stole
a 58-foot bridge.
[ Light laughter ]
Police say they're
on the lookout for a thief
who's described
as having dark hair,
blue eyes, and is the Hulk.
Guys, we have
exactly three shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ Three days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an extraordinary
Christmas sweater
from our
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Now, since there are
three shows left,
let's open door number 3.
Where's 3? Oh, here.
When -- Whenever you're ready.
Go for it.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait. Whoa, whoa, whoa. Yeah.
Let's see it.
Oh. Wow.
Oh, that is -- That is...
That is something.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
Maybe that's --
Look at this thing. Ooh, yeah.
That's like...
Show the back to them?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is space age.
Wow. Fantastic.
Now, let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
242!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi!
Welcome! Hi! Welcome!
Come on over!
Aw, look at you.
Hello. What is your name?
-Karina.
-Karina, where are you from?
-Jersey.
-Yeah! Jersey!
All right, good.
Karina from Jersey.
You already look like
you're in the holiday spirit.
I love the -- But I think that
this will just kind of go
with everything.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
-No one -- You won't stand out
in Jersey if you wear this.
-I know. I'm gonna
go to dinner in this.
-You should.
Would you like to try it on?
-Can I?
-Yes, please.
I think we'd love to see it.
This is gonna be amazing.
I think it's gorgeous.
There...
♪♪
Yeah. It's easy to get on.
[ Laughter ]
Look at this.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you joking me?
Yo. Karina, look at you.
You're...
That looks like
a super model on our show.
It's unbelievable.
Gorgeous.
Thank you so much for
being here! I appreciate it.
Another round of applause
for our winner.
You can leave if you want.
You can stay.
Whatever you feel like doing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Round of applause
for our winner right there.
Stick around!
We got more "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
♪♪